et on va prendre la direction de
l'Allemagne maintenant où nous attend
notre correspondante anne-maillet
bonjour Anne quelle réaction à Berlin
suite à cette intervention russe en
Ukraine
et bien les condamnations se multiplient
ici en Allemagne depuis les premières
heures du jour depuis le début de
l'invasion russe en Ukraine le
chancelier
condamné une violation évidente du droit
international il a assuré à l'Ukraine la
totale solidarité de l'Allemagne dans
ses heures difficiles le sentiment qui
domine ici en Allemagne c'est bien
entendu la consternation voire même la
sidération l'Allemagne ces dernières
semaines vous le savez a eu du mal à
trouver sa place dans le balai
diplomatique on l'a même accusé un
certain temps de complaisance vis-à-vis
de Moscou Berlin c'est finalement
impliqué progressivement aux côtés de la
France au LASAL s'est rendu en Ukraine
en Russie pour négocier une sortie de
crise tous ces efforts ont été piétinés
par Moscou et c'est donc aussi
évidemment un échec pour la diplomatie
allemande cette semaine Berlin avait
finalement décidé de suspendre la
certification du gazeux du cnastream 2
c'était l'un de ses principales leviers
de sanction et comme la confirmer ce
matin l'administralement des Affaires
étrangères à Malena berbock un nouveau
paquet de sanction massive pour
reprendre ses termes contre la Russie
sera présentée à l'issue de multiples
rencontres qui vont se tenir dans le
courant de la journée une vidéo
conférence des chefs d'État de
gouvernement du G7 dont l'Allemagne a la
présidente est prévue pour cet
après-midi avant le sommet d'urgence à
Bruxelles voilà le sommet d'urgence des
dirigeants des des 27 ce soir et puis
les AM